the clark county school district is
continuing its mission to provide more
mental health resources to students and
staff this month the district announced
its partnership with care solace kate
houston breaks down the new service and
how local families are working to
support their kids this school year all
the changes that we have gone through
the last two years
children and adults is being very
stressful families in the clark county
school district are adapting to another
school year with covid 19 restrictions
it varies by age right cameron clark
says while his high schooler is excited
to be back his fifth grader is still
adjusting i think with kids that age
there's a lot of nervous energy and so
for him it's been it's been a little
more tricky other parents are finding
themselves in the same situation
definitely it's hard for them you know
as anybody it's hard for us going to the
store
it's hard for to do anything ccsd is now
rolling out care solace to help anyone
dealing with mental health issues the
service pairs students employees and
their families to emotional support
providers at no cost it's excellent that
the district are adding more resources
for for families margarita romano says
in-person learning was necessary for her
daughter's mental health and is happy to
see the district take additional steps
this school year
it's okay to ask for help it's okay
to talk to somebody when you're feeling
upset as students head further into the
school year clark hopes parents will
have more open conversations about
safety restrictions and mental health i
think the biggest thing is the fear of
the unknown and so if people are not
willing to at least have the
conversations and try to we'll say
manage some of that emotional difficulty
then then it's going to feel like you're
you're sinking kate houston 8 news now
carosa is offered to families with
private insurance medicaid and no
insurance help is available 24 hours a
day every day of the year in any
language